[Music]
foreign
so let's get cracking down with the
Press preview our first look at what is
on tomorrow's front pages and tonight
we'll be checking out the headlines with
the telegraph's chief political
correspondent Camilla Turner and the new
statesman's senior political
correspondent Harry Lambert a very good
evening to both of you we're going to
take a look at front pages uh before we
chat to our guests starting with the
Metro leading with the chance of a stark
warning that will all be paying more tax
following his budget
tax rise is for all an energy help just
for the poorest is the lead story in the
eye
a top a e doctor says he's desperate to
stop his elderly patients from going
into his hospital he fears they'll never
come out again and that's on the front
of the mail
meanwhile the guardian's front page
sends up to a third of England's
hospital beds are filled with patients
well enough to be discharged but with no
suitable places to go
The Daily Telegraph leading with Rishi
sunak telling G20 leaders ahead of the
summit that Russia is a rogue state
on the front page of the times is the
New Deal between the UK and France to
stem the flow of migrants crossing the
channel
and the front of the Daily Star claims
the government has spent more than 250
000 pounds on cheap alcohol in
Parliament in a year while the country
struggles with a cost of living crisis
uh don't forget you can scan the QR code
that you can see on screen throughout
the program there it is you can check
out the front pages often wants papers
while you watch us discussing them and
to discuss them at the telegraph's chief
political correspondent Camilla town and
the new statesman's senior political
correspondent Harry Lambert great to see
you this Sunday evening lots to talk
about so let's get cracking Camilla
front page of the Metro tax Rises
spending cuts and we're all going to
have to pay a little bit more
and yes that's right this Metro front
page is looking ahead to the Autumn
statement this Thursday
um I'm picking up on some comments from
Jeremy Hunt today who we really haven't
had a lot from him personally we've had
plenty of leaks and hints at what might
be in his Autumn statement but his
appearance on on some of the Sunday
shows today
um was the first time really we'd heard
from him properly about what he thinks
um we should all be expecting and I
think what he's been saying both today
and also what we've had over the past
few weeks really
um it is a sort of
experiment in expectation management for
people
um really warming people up to the idea
that there will be public spending cuts
um there will be sort of these tough
decisions
um that the government's making that
people will be paying more tax and just
getting everyone ready is there aren't
any terrible surprises when it comes to
the actual day um of the Autumn
statement I think Jeremy Hunt and also
Rishi sunak have really tried to learn
from the mini budget to experience
underless trust when the public and more
importantly the markets were really
taken by surprise and that led to a
complete panic and a bit of a meltdown
so we're having the opposite here
um lots of um warming people up to what
we can expect this Thursday yeah that's
right Harry isn't it uh Jeremy Hunt
saying today that the markets expect to
see debt being reduced
that's true and I think Camilla's
absolutely right they're doing a much
better job of preparing the ground as
opposed to the Quality era but they
haven't really learned anything from the
era of austerity and I think the the key
fact that's been ignored in all of this
or forgotten is because it's such a
relief to have someone who's seemingly
competent who doesn't want to collapse
the mortgage Market
um through ill thought through policy
we're losing track of the fact that
there's 50 billion that needs to be
found and most of it's going to be found
through spending cuts this is despite
the fact that the political climate's
nothing like it was in 2010. at that
time the British social attitudes survey
showed that about 31 of people wanted
more money in public services which is
relatively low number it's now 52 so
we're just a very different country
we've responded to 10 years of cuts and
people want more money to go in to the
state now of course
money needs to be found but it could be
found through tax Rises it really is
possible to find 50 billion in tax Rises
if this government just to give one
example
was to put uh capital gains tax on um
primary residences which is something
that was discussed is no longer you know
being discussed it's no longer in
today's Metro front page but to do
something like that for instance could
raise 30 billion so I think that's the
key thing to remember there's been
really good expectations management by
hunt and we're seeing that in the story
today but but there is an underlying
story here which is there is ton of
austerity yeah front page of the I uh
same story tax Rises for all and energy
help just for the poorest I mean Camilla
do you think this is the the right
strategy after all general tax Rises go
against the 2019 Manifesto don't they
and we'll surely bring more calls for a
general election
um yes that's right there it's asking me
some who would see um the idea of more
tax Rises as not particularly
conservative of course it's the complete
opposite to the ticket there's trust was
running on promising massive tax cuts
for everyone but I think given the
situation we're now in even those in the
conservative party who are sort of
ideologically opposed um to tax Rises I
think can see
um at least that
um we do need to get our public finances
um sort of controlled we need to be
reassuring the markets and rebuilding
confidence in the British economy
um so if that means doing things that
are not particularly conservative in the
short term but that's all it takes to
get things back on track then perhaps
that is the price we need to pay of
course there are some within the
conservative party some of Russia
sunak's own MPS who probably don't think
this is the right approach and don't
think it's a very conservative way to do
things and that's part of the trouble he
has to try and bring everyone along with
him on this journey
um I think
um as I said before just given the
Fallout from the mini budget we had not
so long ago I think at least people are
prepared now to do things in a different
way
um and to make decisions that just try
to get things back on track again the
other thing that I picked up on is um
this idea that the energy relief which
again underless trust was meant to last
two years and that was meant to be
Universal
um it's now going to stop at six months
and then be focused only on the more
vulnerable members of society so again a
big break with the policy we had under
list trust
um but perhaps something that people can
see
um that given the state of our public
finances it would be a lot to underwrite
um the whole nation's energy bills for a
full two years yeah there is certainly a
sense that uh that higher earners are
going to to to Bear more of the burden
in this Autumn statement and I sorry I
just want to cover One More Story before
we go to the break it's on the front of
the Guardian Harry the hospitals where a
third of patients can't go home it's
something we've covered here on Sky News
quite a lot recently this real issue of
bed blocking where patients are in
hospital they could leave but they've
literally got nowhere to go
well this is the irony isn't it of the
last year which is Rishi sunak
introduced the National Insurance Levy
in order to pay for reforms to social
care we've now had that cut by
quasi-quarting it doesn't look like it's
going to be reintroduced and so the
money isn't there to pay for that social
care reform and if you don't have social
care reform then you have today's story
in the guardian where the NHS is having
to Bear the brunt of the fact that
there's not other parts of the system
that can take people that they'd like to
discharge from hospital and I think the
key fact to remember here again is we're
being asked to find 50 billion the
government spends about
uh 1087 million so you're looking at a
cut of around four percent five percent
the NHS makes up the biggest part of
government spending if you make the NHS
more efficient you can find a lot of the
savings you need and we've really just
lost that argument uh to reform the NHS
and to reform social care and then to
find the efficiencies that way and so
the money that Hunt's having to find
this week is really important to
remember that the consequences of
mismanagement
and failure on a political level over a
long time Camilla really a really quick
thought on this if you could
um yes I think as Harry says this really
shows the close link between
um the social care system and the NHS if
we don't properly reform social care and
have somewhere for perhaps elderly or
other vulnerable patients to go when
they're ready to be discharged from
hospital it just leads to this massive
problem of bed blocking in hospitals and
in turn that leads to delays in NHS
waiting times in ambulance waiting times
and operation waiting time so even
though everyone of course can sympathize
with all these problems in the NHS we
can see that farther down the chain if
we don't sort out social care then it's
just going to make things even worse and
in both the short and long term for for
our hospitals yeah of course okay thank
you both for the moment coming up after
the break
plenty more from the papers including
the latest on the midterms don't go away
[Music]
welcome back Harry and Camilla still
with us let's turn our attention to the
United States Harry the Democrats have
held on to control of the U.S Senate uh
as reported by the metro
to have remarkably I was in Pennsylvania
last week in the buildup from midterms
uh Trump rally in an Obama rally and uh
the mood in the air was that this was
going to be a red wave and it is
shocking because Joe Biden is only on 41
percent approval rating and and tonight
we've got the news that the Nevada
senate seat has finally come in and the
Democrats have secured the Senate
um historically since the war the party
in power has lost about four Senate
seats on average and instead the
Democrats are set to gain one there's
there's one left in Georgia there's
going to be a runoff election in January
and this is this cycle was also uh
the time when Trump seems to have lost a
lot of his power but I think one thing
to say on that which the piece touches
on is that even though Ron DeSantis now
seems like the favorite to become the
Republican nominee in 2024 he will very
much be in the Trump mold you know Trump
may be somewhat finished but trumpism
isn't
Camilla
and yes I think that's right very
interesting
um development here in the US of course
midterms are normally
um at the time when the ruling party
um doesn't fare so well it's an
opportunity for people to sort of add
our grievances
um but in fact um Biden's done much
better than than expected and as Harry
said I think one of the particularly
interesting aspects of all of this is
what it means for Trump and his chances
for a political comeback in the future
that the rise of Ronda Santos and the
sort of following that he's been getting
um and at the same time senior
Republicans turning away from Trump and
blaming him
um for impart as this article points out
back in candidates who actually don't
have popular support so really seeing
this as a blow to the Republicans and
with Trump partly to blame for that
um that's something that many feel could
really Dent his chances of a political
future in the U.S yeah really
interesting stuff isn't it let's finish
Harry with this story about David
Beckham I'll just explain this to us
because Bex has been an ambassador
hasn't he for the the World Cup in Qatar
yeah and uh Joe likes that the comedian
is saying uh he'll give him uh
10K if he pulls out it's not quite clear
why Beckham would take him up on the
other rather than public pressure and we
know we know Beckham to be an honorable
man from his his days queuing in the
state funeral for the queen
so we'll see if he does it but I'll be
amazed if he takes up this um this offer
yeah there's been a lot of controversy
hasn't there
um uh amongst uh celebrities and
commentators who uh have taken quite a
lot of money to to take part in in the
World Cup uh okay we must leave it there
uh We've run out of time we shall speak
to you both again in half an hour so
Camilla and Harry thank you